Wow that's cool look out you see a lot
of the British influence here
[Music]
good afternoon guys in Karachi Pakistan
and today I'm going to bring you into a
few different neighborhoods I'll show
you around
it's been quite a wild trip in this
country two weeks in Pakistan and if you
want a place a city without any tourism
here's your place
Karachi is like nothing else and I've
been to other mad hectic crushing cities
like Delhi or Mumbai and Karachi is
different I'm gonna try to explain that
to you today
and if Karachi was an instrument it
would be a bass drum that's for sure
closer
Shukra
would be a bass drum but the people
people here have been very cool to me
check the bag okay
okay Karachi five six years ago was a
very very dangerous sort of lawless
place bunch of gang clans other groups I
don't really know that all it takes that
place we're fighting for turf everyone
was sort of from the guys I've talked to
they said at night no one is going on
the street people are even scared the
mosque from evening prayer a real sub
and today I'm gonna start here because
it's quiet Karachi's a hectic loud city
and so you can hear me and then we'll
get into the streets into the people
into the life check out a few
neighborhoods have no idea where this is
going but Karachi is one of those places
that it's impossible to be bored things
will happen and activity is there for
the camera that's for sure dope and
that's a stylish cap very nice Sanaa
Malik oh these are the Pakistani Rangers
the Rangers are the elite force here
that keep things secure
once they got this wrong locals tell me
it's a good thing to see Rangers around
they don't seem bought off or corrupt
but I'm a tourist I don't know for sure
sir selfie selfie
okay thank you
this young two weeks two weeks in
Pakistan yeah very good
alone yes what did you say thank you for
coming in a kg thank you buddy
you guys have been awesome what are your
name what are your names
sure here what a loser
[Music]
here we are auntie Bazaar let go what a
bizarre this is one of the center points
I believe and it's rather uncomfortable
right now with the camera so we're gonna
look at some fruits
shaniyah nice okay I'm good thank you
thank you
quick icebreaker people wandering gonna
zoom with the camera
I understand that what am I doing with
the camera
trying to show
what these streets look like
and I think many people question why
which is understandable because everyone
sees the world through their their lands
their perspective
and maybe they don't see what's
extraordinary or different
coming from where I come from
obviously much different an interesting
and this is just wow a lot of
exploration here looks like an old
British building and guessing over there
you know
come on okay so Bosch
right Salameh nickel
very friendly very friendly and that's
the cham of pakistan is the fact that
people are very outgoing welcoming
curious
and like that and that's what you want
when you're traveling your country hello
hello
nice to meet you
now if you want to feel like Brad Pitt
or any famous star and you're not and
then Pakistan is the place to go because
really people give you attention never
alone in this country that's for sure
got a nice piece of architecture here
you can see a lot of the British
influence here in these alleyways come
down into the market little quieter back
here this is nice this is peaceful hello
USA nice to meet you like you thank you
yeah I love it yeah very cool very good
experience
I don't think weak people can survive
here
it's a pretty hard
it hits you pretty hard this city with
all all the stimulation all the senses
get hammered in this country Pakistan
people say New York City doesn't sleep
those people have not been to Karachi
here we go here's a very cool building
with commerce everything you can think
of
TV remotes
socks books within one minute one minute
of walking you can get pretty much
everything you need I wasn't making
videos I'd be wearing one of these
[Music]
this is called empress markets bris
Marty right sir
fruit
nice marble samples
spices
places
it's like there's an echoing effect that
takes place inside one's head
potatoes
potatoes eleven
[Music]
Mosk over here
I've read the greater metropolitan areas
23 24 million people
and of all places in the world that I've
been
felt so like
crushed inside of the city when you're
in the center of a Karachi
you can almost feel the weight of the
whole city
it's not a bad thing I'm just saying
it's like
it's a very intense place
there's no public transport so there is
no Metro the bus service is like this I
don't know if that's a city thing
this bus right here
I'm not sure on that one though you got
some oil issues oh the brake definitely
want that to work
bye-bye everyone smiles everyone waves I
mean what cities have
20 plus million does that happen in
Wow that's cool look how the roof just
sort of teeth
the conditions are perfect but the
design is so cool
look at this roof line here it just
tapers back nice balconies
streamline Moderne look on the corner it
takes a little bit of imagination
because things are falling apart but you
can see that it's quite cool I hope they
restore these
in a way this is super easy blogging
because you just run the camera hello
you just run the camera and there's
something there in another way it's
super hard because look around obviously
the only light bulb guy on the streets
talking in different language
and into a camera so it attracts
attention
and as much as the vibe here is overall
good and people are cool
of course there's some bad apples out
there so you got to be
I'm on your guard to some degree but
friendly enough to have people open up
like that so what is this
minutes fried explai tasty
by the monkey I hate monkeys one yeah
okay one one thank you guys
there you go the wealthy people really
more than anywhere I've been
break themselves away like they're off
in gated communities far from all of
this
this Bharati are Bharati
it was very good nice protein from the
eggs good amount of spice crispy flaky
Joey she'll quite oily it is Pakistan
everything's very oily here okay thank
you thank you sir Pakistan zindabad this
has the guys the police officer how this
neighborhood
and they said it's good you're our
guests we have you protected cops have
all been very cool the cops the Rangers
Special Forces are all over the place
the is I don't really know who those
guys are cuz you can't you just don't
know there
undercover very much
yes nice hit very much take care bye bye
see you guys cricket in the alleyway and
Karachi is one of those cities where
there are all these little veins okay I
call them veins but streets or alleyways
and I need Street there's just a full
community everyone knows everybody the
kids all play with each other it's that
old world that old world stuff that's
very admire a ball I like it like it's
very much connected
[Music]
here we are in a park let's take a
cricket park everyone's playing cricket
they absolutely love their cricket in
this country
[Music]
Clifton Beach this is a beach
destination in the city we've got some
celebration going on here
you can see on my way over here and with
some of the buildings here there's more
money in this neighborhood at least with
the accomodations ports off in the
distance and here we are a beach thank
you one more okay a unique beach
experience I gotta say I don't know what
this is this is like it's not sand it's
not mud
[ __ ]
probably had some oil in it what are we
shooting here I don't want to be on the
other side of this
so I'm gonna go shooting balloons okay
yeah it's quite a bit going on here all
sorts of things
different games people out in the water
a Campbell I don't know if you can see
that out there there's a camel some
four-wheeler action buggsters
you ready
[Music]
you want me to ride the cable I don't
like this they scare me they scare me
I like camels so much it's a beautiful
yes yeah it's a beautiful outward sign
of that from SWOTs beautiful place
beautiful
I'm not ready for I don't
camels that is beautiful
selfies
[Music]
PACA dogs
guys come to Karachi if you want the
bass-drum
if you want the ultimate intense place
crotchy is your place
love these people well that's it guys
day in Karachi and I think I conveyed a
little bit what this place is about only
scratch the surface obviously until next
one
[Music]